hi there Steve Kaufman here to talk
about languages and today I'm going to
talk about grammar errors we all like to
speak as well as we possibly can
we like to pronounce as close to the
native pronunciation as we can and we
would like to make as few errors as
possible however in reality in speaking
a foreign language it's quite normal
not to pronounce quite like the native
the main thing is that we are understood
and it's quite normal to make grammar
errors or errors of usage and here again
the main emphasis should be on being
understood I deal with a lot of
non-native speakers of English have
dealt with in business and I never worry
about their grammar even though there
are certain mistakes that they always
make even people who are very fluent
i've often use the example of you know
german speakers who say I have lived in
Canada since many years where in fact
it's for many years Swedish people who
say you know it is many people in China
he said if there are and typically these
are things that reflect the structures
in their language and yet those people
are very very fluent speakers of English
have a large vocabulary and communicate
very comfortably however we would all
like to do better always or at least
let's put it this way those who would
like to improve their grammar what can
they do so I think one of the biggest
problems with grammar is all of the
terms that are used which contribute
more to confusion than to anything else
because if I for example of the
languages that I speak the best which is
in order
French Japanese and Mandarin and man can
throw baby Spanish and German in there
Swedish um I really don't think about
grammar it on a French I do because we
had so much French at school so we were
for example I still remember in grade 2
or 3 there are 16 verbs that take Etta
as the auxiliary verb and we have to
recite them in class but when I speak
normally I can't go through those 16
verbs to find out if this song you know
to go down is one of the 16 verbs that
takes the auxiliary verb at I have to
get to a point where I naturally say
just sweet day Sunday so the key thing
and of course in Japanese and Mandarin
which I speak quite well and where I
have done a lot of reading and listening
and speaking I have no sense of the
grammar at all none zero I have learned
those languages strictly through massive
reading and listening and then
eventually speaking so I was very
surprised the other day to see a tweet
about intransitive verbs in Japanese I
had never heard of such a term in
Japanese and even the term in transitive
intransitive verbs is kind of confusing
it doesn't help people I am sure that
all the people who had grammar at school
in English people like non-native
speakers of English who studied English
they were taught about transitive and
intransitive verbs and yet so many
people you know they why is it I hear
you but I listen to you you know knowing
that one is transitive intransitive is
not gonna help you you have to get used
to the idea that with the word here
comes you I hear him I hear you with the
word listen you can't listen him you
have to listen to him or I can't say you
I say to you and so we have to get used
to those structures as part of phrases
you know I often use the example of
third-person singular of the present
tense in English everybody knows that
the third-person singular of the present
tense has an S and none of the other
forms of the verb have an S and yet it
says it is such a common mistake he go
even native speakers particularly if
the phrase that comes before it it's a
bit confusing as to which that which
noun governs the verb so we have to get
used to these things as phrases and
therefore in order to get better at
grammar or and I prefer the word usage
because when I was tutoring English at
Linc
what I found was and we had a system
there where we had to identify the type
of mistake that the person made was it
singular plural was it you know tens and
so forth by far the biggest problem was
word usage people don't have a
sufficient sense of what a word what
words mean and which words they are used
with together with in combination with
and so and so you know for example very
common for people to say I am very
interesting in movies instead of
interested now you can get in to all
kinds of terms of Gerrans and
participles or whatever it's not gonna
help that person has to and and I'll get
into what I do but they have to get used
to the ideas I'm interested in that's a
phrase I'm interested in music I'm
interested in art I'm interested in
literature I'm excited about the game
tomorrow I'm not exciting about the game
and there are many many more examples
like that you know so many people
particularly Chinese people Japanese
people even I go even I go you know even
I work hard work hard I want to see even
if even though ok throwing a grammatical
tournament that is not gonna help people
have to focus on it that's why I say in
my own case say Slavik case endings I
just have to save the phrases say in
link focus on those phrases here's how
it you know very often the preposition
will determine the case or certain verbs
determine the case and so I have to
highlight those if I'm reading in a book
I underline them if I'm listening I
listen for it and slowly with enough
with enough exposure to the language
through listening and reading and I
might add
you know I eventually have to speak and
you have to use the words I often say
when I'm starting in a language I do a
lot of listening and reading to build up
my vocabulary and I'm approaching 3,000
words in Arabic so I'll soon have to
start speaking ugh but not argh I'm
looking forward to it
but you have to start using it and
making mistakes and get the mistakes
corrected and you'll make the mistake
again and slowly the brain gets used to
the structure the usage in the language
and all of our brains are capable of
learning and acquiring the language in
this way not all of us can understand
the grammatical terms the grammatical
explanation is not all of us want to do
the drills but if we expose ourselves to
enough of the content and if we want to
improve you know and very often no first
of all let me say so when I start
speaking with the tutor
at link I get back a report with 1015
phrases where I made a mistake so I then
import these a nice study these phrases
and very likely the next three or four
times at least from my own experience
that I speak with a tutor I will make
the same mistake again and I'll get it
corrected again but over time gradually
I'll start you know improving with
regard to these structures but I also
notice other structures if I'm attentive
to the language if I'm doing enough
listening and reading and so gradually
gradually my usage my word usage my you
know accuracy in terms of using the
structures of the language will improve
and so rather than relying on
grammatical terms and grammatical
explanations the issue is here's how we
say this in say English which is my
language or whatever your language
happens to be this is how we say this in
my language here's how they say it in
the language that I am learning so this
structure or this phrase equals this
phrase and so gradually as you're
listening to content and reading and
making meaning of it and and starting to
rely on the structures of the language
you are learning
the brain is slowly getting used to it
and so I think with regard to grammar
errors in fact there's all kinds of
research that shows that correcting
doesn't change things I have some
difficulty with this because corrections
is one of the ways in which you start to
notice what's happening in the language
it doesn't correct you overnight and you
need to be corrected many many times but
it's part of what helps you notice
massive exposure helps you notice
wanting to notice helps you notice also
we are often aware of which structures
we feel less confident about and so
therefore we try when we see them we
underline them and we try to focus on
them so with regard to grammar errors
then to summarize I wouldn't be too
worried about making grammar areas if
grammar errors if the main goal is to
communicate obviously if you are writing
on behalf of a company then you know you
don't want to make errors it looks silly
if some official you know whatever
letter like the White House where there
are errors but it is just communication
the odd error shouldn't make you
tongue-tied or worried just as your
pronunciation needn't be perfect however
we all strive to improve and so
therefore you should have a strategy
which it doesn't rely on grammar
correction but does accept correction as
a step towards noticing better you
should rely on reading grammatical
explanations but sometimes reviewing a
small grammar book can be helpful not
for the grammatical terms but because
you see examples there of what is
correct usage in that language and build
up your vocabulary if you do a lot of
reading you'll get a better and better
sense of how words are used what the
scope of meaning of words is which words
they're used together with all of this
kind of thing and your brain will
gradually get used the language but
there are no shortcuts you have to
engage with the language so there you
have it
grammar errors bye for now
[Music]